pop
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
il
en allemagne on a toujours tendance à
dire qu'un château et romantique
[Musique]
mais je crois que celui ci celui de line
stein mérite ce qualificatif
il est là sur minoritaire dans le
franken valdes pas très loin de la
frontière actuelle de la rd1
[Musique]
je
et à la mi février de 1944 une voiture
une mercedes qui arrivait le berlin
s'est arrêté devant ce chan
[Musique]
m
le chauffeur est allé ouvrir la portière
et en est descendu à tout petit homme
oui un mètre soixante aux cheveux blancs
serré frileusement dans une capote
d'officier de marine
cet homme là c'était l'amiral 'canaris'
l'amiral wilhelm 'canaris' l'un des
hommes peut être les plus puissants du
troisième reich
l'organisateur de l'un des plus
inquiétants services secrets de
l'histoire
l'app vert à l'homme s'est avancé au
devant lui c'était le lieutenant-colonel
phoques qui était commandant de ce
château et l'a accueilli canaris ce
qu'il a salué une faut dire d'un air
assez maussade
qu'est ce que ces textes château et bien
tout simplement un bastion de l'awb vers
un bastion des services secrets
allemands
alors est-ce que kanari's venait
inspecter son bastion pas du tout
canarie c'était là comme un prisonnier
il y avait longtemps qu entre l'ap vers
le service secret de l'armée allemande
de la wehrmacht l usd le service des ss
il y avait longtemps que le torchon
brûle et il y avait longtemps que les ss
avaient juré la perte de canaris 20 fois
il avait cru les tendres pour le compte
et 20 fois il s'était relevé par la
force de son intelligence génial
détournant les coûts et même les
retournant à son avantage
cela ne pouvait durer éternellement
un jour c'était à la fin de la première
quinzaine de février 1944 deux hommes
s'étaient présentés à 0,6
là où canaris savait son bureau central
de la devait ça n'était pas des anonymes
ces deux hommes là c'était tout
simplement le maréchal keitel chef de
l'auberge commando des revers mart et le
général jodl chef de l'état major de
cette même vers marque
les deux militaires du plus haut rang en
allemagne et ils étaient venus d'irak
anne harris le führer a décidé la fusion
du sd le service secret ss et de
l'abwehr votre service alors qu'elle
harris avait compris que tout à coup lui
qui était tout il n'était plus rien et
d'ailleurs cailletet leyio de lavey
qu'on imagine quand même une certaine
gêne lui avait dit le führer vous invite
à vous rendre aussitôt au château
d'olonne stein où vous attendrez ses
ordres
et je n'imagine cet homme là dans ce
château errant dans ce château dans cet
hiver rigoureux
je suis sûr qu'ils ne cherchent pas à
visiter il connaît très bien ce domaine
mais peut-être que ce qu'ils cherchent
tout simplement s'est lui même
[Musique]
car même quarante ans après aujourd'hui
nous ne savons pas piller l'amiral
'canaris' j'ai lu tous les livres qu'on
lui a consacré pour les uns c'est un
serviteur fanatiques dix plaies qu'il a
aidés dès sa prise de pouvoir
il a forgé à son service ce formidable
instrument qu'est la verrerie
parmi ceux qui ont fait le triomphe
éphémère dit claire en première place
l'amiral kanharith voilà ce qu'ils
écrivent certains mais d'autres écrivent
mais pas du tout
c'était un résistant 'canaris' dans
l'ombre
associé à la résistance clandestine anti
hitlérienne
il a porté des coups tél à hitler
qu'hitler a connu la chute un héros
'canaris' un héros qu'il faut admirer
respecter ma faim voilà donc deux
portraits complètement différente de
portraits complètement contradictoire
alors lequel des deux est juste quarante
ans après nous avons du mal à répondre
alors lui
litière
qui marche des heures et des heures
chaque jour ici dans ce château
[Musique]
est ce qu'il s'y retrouve lui-même
tout est insolite g 'canaris' à
commencer par les origines au xvième
siècle on trouve près du lac de côme des
canaris zay où ils sont italiens puis
ils voyagent au xviiie siècle il arrive
en rhénanie ils deviennent canaris s'ils
deviennent allemand le père du petit
wilhelm canaries c'est un ingénieur
devenu directeur de puissantes acier
année aux fourneaux
[Musique]
duisbourg c'est là qu'il grandit petit
garçon taciturne amoureux des lettres
des arts de la musique
jalousé par ses camarades au lycée au
guide nasion parce que chaque matin
c'est une calèche qui la mène et le soir
c'est une calèche qui vient le chercher
[Musique]
il habite une maison somptueuse un
immense pari fait du cheval
quand il était adolescent
[Musique]
imaginez la surprise de monsieur canaris
ce père canson et step deux fils lui
annonce après avoir poursuivi des études
brillantes qu'il veut se faire marin
pourquoi veux tu être marin le père n'a
pas eu le temps de s'y opposer il est
mort à 52 ans un peu plus qu si madame
'canaris' a accepté il a passé les
examens le voilà officiellement son
premier voyage le conduit en amérique du
sud pays d'instabilité politique
traditionnelle il observe tout cela
l'argentine le brésil et s'est dit que
l'on pourrait utilement avoir là-bas des
agents allemands ou plutôt des
autochtones qui accepteraient de
travailler pour l'allemagne voilà un
garçon qui n'a guère plus de vingt ans
et il met en place avec l'accord de son
commandant bien sûr des correspondants
et il adresse un rapport aux affaires
étrangères à berlin qui suscite
l'étonnement et l'admiration
pas mal ce préambule de la vie du futur
amiral 'canaris'
en 14 18 il est de nouveau dans ces eaux
là
son bateau qui est un vieux rafiot
poursuivi par une escadre britannique
doit se réfugier en eau chilienne dans
l'archipel de juan fernandez il se
saborde ils sont tous internes et par
les chiliens
normalement il est prisonnier jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre et ses vannes faux
passeport ils s'embarquent pour
l'espagne il traverse l'espagne et puis
réussi à regagner l'allemagne
c'est un exploit alors on le remercie et
félicite et on se dit que ce
qu'analysent son pourrait l'utiliser
autrement que sur un bateau on va le
renvoyer en l'espagne pour mettre au
point des bases de ravitaillement pour
les sous-marins allemands et il réussit
admirablement dans cette mission
nouvelle étape de la vie future de
l'espion 'canaris' il est commandant
d'un sous-marin on méditerranée
lorsqu'il apprend la capitulation de
l'autriche d'abord il est temps de
remonter vers la baltique de rejoindre
l'allemagne est à peine est il arrivé en
allemagne que c'est la fatale nouvelle
l'allemagne elle aussi à déposer les
armes
le voilà ce jeune officier de marine sur
la jetée à qui il avec les autres
officiers qui ont tout perdu
désespéré et il va arriver une sorte de
géant moustachu un peu comme un viking
ou un de ses anciens germain et on lui
dit senna sq nask c'est un social
démocrate un agitateur devant la guerre
les chefs du parti
par tradition kanari's des tests lui
c'est un conservateur
c'est un traditionaliste et un
monarchiste il a prêté serment à
l'empereur au kaiser est pour lui que le
kaiser est appliquée c'est la fin du
monde alors un social démocrate qu'il
déteste
et pourtant voilà que ce géant se met à
parler et il émeut ghana a dit oui nous
avons perdu la guerre et ce qui est pire
maintenant c'est que ceux qui gronde à
travers l'allemagne
c'est la rébellion c'est le mutinerie
c'est la révolution l'armée victimes
la marine se rebelle le drapeau rouge
partout le chaos
est-ce qu'en plus d'avoir perdu la
guerre de la londe perdre l'allemagne et
c'est un langage qui plaît à canarie et
il sent que tant pis social-démocrate et
peut-être son ennemi politique mais
c'est un homme avec qui on peut
travailler il va s'associer aux chars de
norsk va le rejoindre à berlin
noski qui est décidé à tout pour
rétablir l'ordre et l'ordre c'est le mot
sacré comprennent harris noski qui va
même faire appel à des commandos
d'extrême droite qu'on appelle les corps
francs avec le capitaine pape ce qui a
pris 'canaris' comme adjoint on se bat
dans les rues il y à un homme une femme
que l'extrême droite exècre ce sont deux
communistes c'est les brèches tu essaies
rosa luxembourg et dans les milieux
d'extrême droite on décide de les
éliminer
ils sont assassinés l'un et l'autre
celui qui a tué rosa luxembourg c'est un
lieutenant du nom de fog
alors là c'est un peu trop fort on
l'arrête on va le juger
il est en prison un jour une voiture
s'arrête devant la prison un officier en
descend il ya un ordre avec tous les
temps fond il faut transférer vos
gueules dans une autre prison le
directeur ou confié l'officier l'ordre
étaient
ap les 'canaris' ont tout cela a été
discuté longuement 'canaris' à nier
toute sa vie il avait fait cela mais
nous sommes aujourd'hui en phase de
documents qui ne nous laisse plus de
doute
d'ailleurs le capitaine pape ce qu'il
savait de quoi il parlait elle a dit oui
ces canaris ce qui a fait évader bogle
quelques temps plus tard on va plus loin
encore à certains cap
un haut fonctionnaire avec des officiers
des généraux fomentent un putsch c'est
le putsch de gap qui prend le pouvoir à
berlin
[Musique]
ça ne tient que quelques jours les
syndicats décrètent la grève générale et
le putsch ces fonds mais 'canaris' a
adhéré qu'elle n'a risqué dans sa ligne
la tradition la conservation l'armée
landes alors c'est grave et après
l'échec du putsch on l'arrête avait
beaucoup d'autres il va lui arriver
certainement des bricoles à kaunas
oui mais voilà c'est qu'il ne reste que
quelques jours en prison c'est que les
charges qui pesait sur lui tout à coup
s'évanouissent les pièces disparaissent
les témoins refusés témoigner et plus
rien moi ça fait ghana déjà pendant des
années il va servir
tantôt dans les états-majors tantôt sur
des unités et il a ramené vers la
baltique sa jeune femme et will say my
il s'est marié avec une certaine erick
cavaglia fille d'un industriel qui n'a
que deux ou trois ans de moins que lui
une artiste c'est eric à qui elle
raffole de musique qui joue du violon et
c'était ricard
en 2000 en est tombé amoureux il a
épousé à la fin de l'année 1919
alors oui aussi bien sur les bateaux
qu'elle était majeure
il va prendre attache de relever la
marine allemand et il est réussi avec
d'autres parce que la marine n'existe
plus après la guerre après traité de
versailles
elle arrive à voyager à l'étranger
hollande en espagne où il va nouer des
relations précieuse notamment avec un
certain franco française qu franco des
civils des officiers qu'il retrouvera
plus tard il va au japon où l'on
fabrique des sous marins pour l'armée
japonaise sous licence allemand une faut
que canaris soit là c'est ça déjà
canaries et puis il est nommé commandant
du navire écoles des cadets de la marine
allemand et sur ce navire il y un jeune
cadet justement qui est un grand garçon
d'un mètre 90 se massent au visage
osseux au visage dur qui s'appellera
hennaert et id riches vous êtes d'accord
que c'est un nom qui évite des
explications et heydrich va vouer une
véritable vénération au commandant
canarus et que l'artiste va parler avec
lui va prendre qu il est musicien
violoniste et c'est vrai que
il joue à partie dans un quatuor qui les
uns mozartien à vertou il y aura des
concerts
quatuor à cordes chez kanari's avec
madame canaris série k avec rhein art et
riche deux autres
amitié affection reinhard heydrich
devient un peu comme l'enfant de la
maison ça dure deux ans cette importance
là pour l'avenir kanari's la ville
en 1932 il est avril lorsque tout à coup
on répète autour de lui cette même
phrase il arrive qui il arrive
vous savez en 1932 quand on dit il
arrive tout le monde sait qu'il s'agit
d' adolf hitler
qui termine cette opération incroyable
de conquête d'un pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est en mai 1932 au sommet de sa
popularité
[Musique]
martillac et indépendant l'action
mitraille itten aussi put them all stars
i way
[Musique]
et
il a parlé à toutes les catégories de
citoyens en allemagne il a choisit
maintenant de parler aux marins et il
est là sur la tribune bloc ce que cannes
à risque le voit l écoute et hitler dean
tend vers le pouvoir
je redonnerai à l'allemagne une marine
digne d'elle parce qu'il n'y a pas de
grands pays sans puissante marine
imaginer l'ovation fantastique qui ça
lui plaît
[Applaudissements]
ecalle harris est bouleversé
[Musique]
et quand il apprendra au début 2009 133
que le vieux maréchal hindenburg vient
de remettre le poste de chancelier
d'allemagne
adolf hitler il est profondément heureux
il ya une légende je voulais dit je vous
le redire et une légende autour de
canaris on l'a présenté comme ayant
toujours été réticent devant il pleure
c'est faux il y à des documents
d'archivés
on ne peut pas discuter il a salué avec
enthousiasme
l'avènement du nazisme comme d'ailleurs
des millions d'allemands
[Musique]
hélas même organisé des conférences sur
les bateaux il a expliqué aux équipages
ce qu était hitler ce qu'était le
national socialisme
il fallait être aussi fidèle à hitler
qu'on l'avait été à l'emploi parce que
leclerc c'était l'allemagne
il explique tout cela conférences
exposés et pourtant il a failli se
brouiller avec les neiges goering
ministre président de la prusse via un
jour visiter le bateau que commande
'canaris' et puis on s'en va au large et
les malades gislain pas le pied marin
c'est un aviateur et alors il veut me
tout ce qu'il avait dans l'estomac
ça amuse beaucoup les marins il descend
metz pour prononcer un discours
et là il ya un jeune lieutenant qui dit
général göring nous vous déclare ont
désormais rice protecteur de la
nourriture des poissons
il devrait sourire goering banon il n'a
pas le sens de l'humour rentrer à berlin
il téléphone à l'amiral il faut
sanctionner sur lieutenant l'amiral
donne l'ordre à canary ce sens yonnais
le lieutenant canaris se déclare pas du
tout il n'a pas outrepassé les limites
d'un humour ont admis sur les bateaux
alors l'amiral insiste kanari's se
braque et finalement les temps disgrâce
canaris sont l'envoi mon dieu pour
surveiller les côtes de la baltique
c'est pas très brillant il va
s'installer dans une nouvelle résidence
avec sa femme et ses deux filles où il a
deux filles dont une est anormal il en
souffrira toute sa vie et dont l'autre
ne l'aiment guerre madame 'canaris'
d'ailleurs non plus plus cela va et plus
canaries sera un homme seul
marié bien sûr mais avec une épouse
très lointaine et des enfants sans
infection
il faut savoir cela pour mieux connaître
'canaris' il est là résigné pas résigné
parce que quel respect par un homme à se
résigner
apparemment résignée lorsqu'il apprend
qu'on le convoque à berlin et pourquoi
et bien parce que le capitaine de
vaisseau patsy vient de démissionner qui
est bâti ch c'est tout simplement le
chef du sr du service de renseignement
de l'armée allemand l'aber intéressant
pourquoi at il démissionné savez après
la guerre de 14 18 il n'y avait plus de
s es dont l'art est constitué
attiches en a pris la tête a fait du bon
travail mais voilà c'est que à partir de
l'avènement d'hitler il y eut
parallèlement à l'ap vers le sd
l'easyshare dienst c'est à dire le
service secret et ss7 himmler qui en a
eu l'idée en 1931 et depuis c'est
heydrich mais oui à idriss le voilà qui
reparaît qui en a pris la tête heydrich
qui était devenu officiel marine mais
qui avait un beau jour fait des
promesses de mariage à une jeune fille
et il n'avait pas épouser il avait comme
andy déshonoré cellu m6 plainte de la
famille on ne présentait pas dans la
marine allemande friedrich a été cassé
et en contre hitler et se jette dans la
national socialisme et il devient le
chef du sd alors oui quand il est là au
pouvoir sans cesse il se heurte à tsy
parce que ceci est du ressort du sd non
dit pas tiges de la baie et finalement
être justement le départ de pat ich qui
démissionnera vit d'ailleurs et on dit
apathie conseillez vous pour vous
succéder il répond 'canaris'
souvenez-vous de ce qui l'a fait
précédemment
il a pris ses fonctions le 1er janvier
voilà
'canaris' à la tête de la baie il est là
dans son bureau il a convoqué ses
collaborateurs il le voit tel qu'il est
sauvé il n'a pas grandi ses cheveux ont
prématurément blanchis et aussitôt ses
collaborateurs l'appellerons le vieux
en fait il n'a que 47 ans et il les
regarde et il leur dit messieurs j'ai
décidé qu ici à l'ap vers nous
reprendrons une devise de mon illustre
prédécesseur le colonel fond de nicolaï
qui a présidé aux destinées du sr
pendant la guerre 14-18 et qui disait le
renseignement c'est une affaire de
gentilshommes c'est tout ce que j'avais
à vous dire messieurs et un témoin
client l'a déposée dira plus tard j'ai
ressenti à l'instant le choc a été très
brutal le courant a passé je me suis dit
nous avons un patron est oui avait un
patron à la faire et quel patron ce que
veut 'canaris' ces données à l'allemagne
a service de renseignement militaire
digne de l'idée qu'il se fait de
l'allemagne
et cette idée est immense
pour lui rien ne compte
on ce monde que son pays que sa patrie
que l'allemagne c'est le patriote c'est
le nationaliste dans toute l'acception
du terme
[Musique]
et une femme être patiemment sur pied
une immense organisation qui à son
apogée en 1938 comportera cinq sections
la section extérieur dirigé par le vice
amiral burkina la section z chargé de
l'organisation des autres sections
dirigée par le capitaine puis commandant
puis colonel puis général austère la
section 1 chargé du renseignement
dirigée par le colonel pire une banque
la section deux chargés du sabotage et
de la subversion dirigé d'abord par le
majeur grosse courte puis par le colonel
la hausse de la section iii espionnage
et contre-espionnage dirigés par le
major bamba puis par le colonel von
benti veille
parallèlement à ces cinq sections une
division des billes on remet la division
brandebourg
chargé des opérations de sabotage et de
commandos commandée par le général von
choltitz voilà l'organisation de la paix
or ce qui est bien intéressant à noter
c'est que sur ces cinq chefs de section
collaborateur direct de canaris ce droit
sont des anti nazi canaris cela toujours
su il les a pourtant mis en place alors
est ce qu'il est déjà devenu anti nazi
est ce qu'il a changé si vite
pas du tout il reste fidèle à hitler
parce que hitler c'est l'ordre et
'canaris' aime l'ordre
je pense surtout que là choisissez
sommes là par souci d'efficacité
parce qu'ils pensent que ces hommes là
feront de très bons chefs d' espions
c'est cela son travail mais peut-être
aussi que canal ce qui ne laisse jamais
rien au hasard a choisi ces sommes là
pour se dire qu'il lui fallait des
hommes dans tous les camps et cela va
aller très vite
en deux années là devers est partout et
là des agents partout qu'elle harris a
retrouvé ses relations d'autrefois tous
ces gens qu'ils voyaient lors de ses
voyages
quand ils allaient à l'étranger pour la
marine
ses amis ses relations il avait noté
tous leurs noms il avait gardé des
rapports avec eux et bien voilà des gens
qui allaient être à la base la plupart
du temps des nouveaux réseaux de
l'abwehr et voilà des hommes qui
m'aiment bien plus tard seraient des
agents de la cinquième colonne il a
toujours vu loin
alors tout est en place savez vous que
très rapidement il va être en possession
de tous les plans de la marine française
l'organisation mais aussi les plans
d'entrée en guerre de la marine et même
du code secret de la marine française
c'est à l'officier qui a vendu ses plans
officiels français qui sera d'ailleurs
fusillé mais le mal était fait et
partout c'est la même chose
il a fait de la berre quelque chose de
considérable alors le sd1 oui le sd de
vahid riches il n'a pas changé dans ses
ambitions le sd a tendance à tenir le
renseignement c'est nous de quoi vous
mêlez vous vous aver lorsque sous
prétexte de vous renseigner sur des
étrangers vous vous renseigner sur les
communistes les communistes nous regarde
nous sd alors les heurts continuent mais
tout est différent puisque cette
heydrich et puisque c'est 'canaris' les
deux hommes ont renoué alors idriss
revient chez canaris ce joug du violent
chez 'canaris' avec madame 'canaris' et
le matin canaris saïd riches qui aime le
cheval vont galoper dans le même bois
étrillé contrer tri il est prudent
'canaris' ne fait rien au hasard
quand il avance un pion ils essaient à
l'as vence où il va il sait jusqu'où il
ne faut pas aller trop loin comme a dit
un jour cocteau
[Musique]
en 1936 en espagne c'est la guerre
civile
[Musique]
on est allé chercher aux canaris sans
calembours aux îles canaries en général
qui s'appelle le général francisco
franco pour le transporter au maroc
espagnole où il va prendre le
commandement de l'armée espagnole du
maroc et ce qu'il faut c'est transporter
cette armée en espagne contre le
gouvernement républicain
oui mais voilà la marine et l'aviation
espagnole sont fidèles au gouvernement
républicain comment transporter cette
armée est franco va s'adresser à
mussolini qui hésitent qui finira par
accepter et eide l'envoyé de franco est
arrivé à byron parce qu'il clair tout le
monde le sait aime la musique de wagner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir-là il a assisté deux
représentations de wagner les ont vus
présente l'envoyer espagnol flanqué de
deux allemands ses amis qui explique la
demande du général franco des avions
[Musique]
éclair à peine l'envoyer espagnol par
qui entre sa résidence convoque
immédiatement goering le général von
blomberg chef de l'état major allemand
et puis quel âge s'ils sont là tous les
trois ils sont venus le aussi écouter
valnet on vient de faire sa cour que
dois-je faire de marie claire maurier
compte mal sur eure sommes en train de
rire mais nous ne sommes qu'au début
n'allons pas perdre des avions la base
folle imprudence faut refuser von
blomberg est dubitatif
j'avoue que votre place je saisis très
mal furet 'canaris' n'a rien dire voilà
qui parle
je crois qu'il faut accepter
pourquoi devant nucléaire parce qu'il
s'agit du général franco
je le connais manurhin le connais
nativement je le tutoie et il fait un
portrait idéal de franco et il ajoute si
franco le départ que par l'espagne les
communistes triompheront l'espace comme
liszt et leurs motifs dits clair et si
le communisme triomphe en espagne la
france livré au front populaire
basculera dans le communisme le
communisme sur le rhin minefield
et hitler décide d'envoyer les avions et
les pilotes
[Musique]
et à la fin du mois d'août 1936 l'armé
du maroc est passé en espagne
la suite vous la connaissez
[Musique]
franco n'oubliera jamais le rôle joué
par 'canaris' oui les lancer également
dans la fronde politique internationale
et on peut dire là que ceux qui
affirment que canaries c'est un homme
qui a bien servi hitler ont raison mais
ont-ils totalement parce que une menace
se dessine sur l'autriche et 'canaris'
le sens l'un des premiers kills en tous
cas la pierre a décidé d'avaler
l'autriche il l'a écrit dans mein kampf
tout ce qu'il a fait il l'avait annoncé
dans son livre mein kampf
voilà on l'a mal lu ce livre hélas il
n'a pas cru et pour clarisse c'est une
erreur d'absorber l'autriche parce qu'il
est sûr que les puissances démocratiques
la france l'angleterre ne laisserons pas
faire heatley ce sera la guerre et
hitler mais pas suffisamment réarmer
pour s'exposer à une gaie et canards
sont tentés par des rapports de toutes
sortes l'empêcher d'entrer en autriche
mais il connaît malgré tout mal heatley
qui a emballé les rapports de cannes
harris et il entre en autriche c'est la
loose
[Musique]
à
elle triomphe à vienne
[Musique]
à l'accueil mans
[Applaudissements]
des folles d'acclamations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le césar des temps modernes canaris sa
souris des îles et là ils écoutent ces
acclamations
ce torrent d'entousiasme qui coule au
tourne hitler il le voit et il était
venu en tant qu'allemand voilà le
dilemme tragique de tous les opposants
et l'est comment choisir entre l'état et
la patriote le service de la patrie et
le service de l'état
quand cet état s'appelle hitler alors
autour de lui il y a les anti nazi
notamment austère qui l'implorent qui
lui dit mais vous devriez démissionner
votre démission frais grands traits fait
ils refusent parce qu'il tient à son
adverse
et voilà encore son île m il n'a pas
envie de s'arracher de son l'abwehr de
son oeuvre et en même temps il dit si je
pars ce sont les ss qui s'empareront de
la berre et il a raison alors ils y
restent et ils continuent à forger cet
instrument incomparable qui va aider
heatley et en même temps ils tremblent
quand ils voient hitler convoité la
tchécoslovaquie il comprend que certains
de ses adjoints il les a pris et des
liaisons secrètes avec les anglais et
heidi racer roberts band site à watts
churchill soyez ferme
ne le laissez pas aller plus loin c'est
la paix du monde qui est en jeu il sait
tout cela canal
mais il n'a pas lui même participé à ces
négociations secrètes ils l'espèrent ils
ne dénoncent pas voile dans l'ambiguïté
de qena rice en tant que chef de
l'abwehr il devrait dénoncer puisque
c'est en quelque sorte de la trahison
ils ne dénoncent pas mais en même temps
il n'encourage pas vraiment
ppr se moque tout ce que peuvent
rapporter les agents de 'canaris' une
lettre de churchill qui dit que s'il
s'en prend à la tchécoslovaquie ce sera
la guerre du ballet cette lettre et la
suite vous la connaissez les français
les anglais qui s'aplatissent à munich
[Musique]
d'abord la moitié de la thur cela va qui
absorbé et puis au printemps 1939 le
reste
[Musique]
et hitler qui arrive toujours comme un
césar des temps anciens
clarisse désespéré alors il n'y a plus
qu'une solution dans les milieux de
l'art mais on sait que s'il va plus loin
il clair s'il s'en prend la pologne
comme cela est prévisible ce sera la
guerre la guerre fatal alors une seule
solution chasse et hitler de pouvoir
selon conspirent autour du général beck
le chef d'état major le nouveau chef
d'état major de l'armée autour de
l'ancien bourgmestre de stuttgart coeur
de l'est il ya pratiquement tous les
grands noms de l'armée allemande
chassez heatley alors à la conspiration
seront tati généraux qui commande les
forces stationnées à berlin et dans les
environs ces forces vont s'emparer au
jour j des points stratégiques de la
capitale
on arrêtera les ss on les empêchera
d'entrer dans berlin et on mettra en
état d'arrestation hitler et tous ses
ministres après quoi on procédera à des
élections libres et un gouvernement
démocratique sera au pouvoir qu'il n'y
aura pas de guerre dès le premier jour
canaries c'est tout il écoute il laisse
fait il sait pas lancer lui même dans la
conspiration
peut-être parce qu'il est lucide parce
qu'il sait que ses généraux réunis dans
des chambres secrètes ses généraux parle
beaucoup il sait que ses généraux
finalement ne vous ont rien fait il y a
le général alder qui se promène partout
avec un revolver le général albert qui a
dit quand je serai devant hitler jeu
l'abattre est là avec ce revolver dix
fois il est en présence des plaies et il
ne tire pas et quand ses camarades
s'étonne il dit que ce que vous voulez
devant lui je suis comme foudroyé
oui canaries sera un jour cette boutade
au fond ces généraux ne feront un coup
d'état contre hitler que lorsque celui
ci
leur en donnera l'ordre alors c'est sa
lucidité et le conduit à ne pas
s'engager
il laisse partir pour rome l'un de ses
collaborateurs joseph muller qui vient
dire au vatican
il faut que l'angleterre et la france
aide les conjurés parce que ainsi s'ils
les aides on l'évitera la guerre et
l'angleterre répond ben que les conjurés
prennent le pouvoir on les aidera après
rien ne se passe
une fois de plus 'canaris' a laissé
faire il sait très bien qui a été dire
joseph muller arômes et n'a pas pris
l'initiative de séné le ciation de cette
démarche mais il ne dénoncera pas non
plus joseph mul
quand hitler rentrer en pologne canarus
déclare c'est la fin de l'allemagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on commence à critiquer beaucoup
'canaris' dans l'entourage du führer
qu'est ce que c'est que ces rapports qui
l'acculé l'autriche ce serait la guerre
la tchécoslovaquie ce serait la guerre
on n'a rien vu la pologne ce serait la
guerre c'est exact pour une fois il ne
s'est pas trompé mais on devait la
perdre cette guerre on l'a gagné qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
alors on interroge canaris 600 de la
suspicion il faut dire qu'à chaque fois
il répond superbement car c'est un homme
qui s'est toujours admirablement
défendre ses positions
il est allé en pologne c'est son rôle
parce qu'il faut voir ce qu'est la
pologne conquise et ce qu'il voit le
bouleverse
[Musique]
et villes rasées les populations anéanti
les élites exterminer les juifs arrêtés
ne violence qu'ils n'auraient pas
soupçonner conduit du a jusqu'à z les ss
il revient à terré avec des dossiers
qu'il va montrer successivement à tous
les généraux en leur disant ce que
l'armée va laisser faire éternellement
[Musique]
et nous savons par des témoins que
l'émotion la colère de paris c'était
sincère mais nous devons aussi observé
que les archives démontre qu'à certains
moments pas nombreux mais à certains
moments l'abwehr a tout de même prêté la
main à côté des ssd exactions
inexcusable
[Musique]
nous
décidément tout cela n'est pas simple
vous êtes bien d'accord avec moi alors
maintenant il s'agit de savoir où ira
heatley qui éclairait décidé il ya an
battu la pologne d'attaquer la france
ils veulent attaquer tout de suite et
autour de canaris sont se dit non il
faut encore l'en empêcher il faut qu'il
soit battu on en est là dans l'entourage
de cannabis austère le colonel austère
en est là savez vous ce que va faire le
colonel austère l'un des chefs de
sections de l'abwehr et c'est ça qui est
sidérant
il va communiquer est l'attaché
militaire néerlandais sas les dates
successives arrêté par hitler et
notamment la dernière le 10 mai 1940
pour l'attack à l'ouest
oui l'abwehr un chef de section de
l'abwehr informe les ennemis de
l'allemagne de la date à laquelle on va
les attaques et ça c'est de la trahison
vous savez la position de l'austère
n'est pas confortable loin de là il est
désespéré il dit à l'un de ses amis ce
que je fais c'est bien pire que de tuer
ou de se tuer
et oui c'est 'canaris' lui aussi c'est
ce que fait austère ça n'est pas lui qui
lui a dit de le faire mais il sait ce
qu'il fait il ne l'arrêtent pas et il ne
le dénonce pas alors l'ambiguïté ici est
totale vous savez qu'en france
le haut commandement nommé coûtera pas
les avertissements qui ont été données
[Musique]
ce sera la france à son tour anéanti
[Applaudissements]
et de nouveaux 'canaris' désespérée que
fait devant cet honneur qui gagne
toujours
que faire et le dilemme va se poursuivre
donc à nice
à travers l'europe l'abwehr est à son
maximum d'efficacité dans les
territoires occupés la berd démantèle
les réseaux de résistance avec une
différence c'est que les résistants s'en
souviendront il valait mieux être
arrêtée et interrogée par l'ats berck
par le sdss oui elle frappe la bière
elle frappe bien et elle sert bien
l'allemagne
donc le régime le dilemme est en même
temps quand hitler envoie 'canaris'
auprès de franco pour que kanari's
convaincre franco de s'allier à
l'allemagne 'canaris' dit à franco en
secret il ne faut pas que tu tally à
l'allemagne parce que si tu t'habilles
alain magnier bien y plaire traversera
ton pays sera en afrique du nord
si hitler domine le bassin méditerranéen
il gagnera la guerre il ne faut pas
qu'il gagnera gay oui la kanari's
s'engage il a préparé franco à la
rencontre la fameuse rencontre
diplomatique d'hendaye où hitler
rencontré franco et après cette
rencontre qui a duré sept heures hitler
a dit je préfèrerais me faire arracher
quatre dents que de revoir ce ce jésuite
donc analystes avaient bien préparé et
il qu'un n'a pas insisté car à cette
époque qu'il avait en tête quand même
avant l'espagne il avait l'antenne
d'envahir l'angleterre à trois reprises
au cours de la guerre et notamment
comment les allemands occupé toute la
zone libre de france
il clair à envoyer 'canaris' auprès de
franco pour lui demander de venir à ses
côtés 'canaris' bien entendu lui donner
des arguments anti hitlérien le seul
geste que ce soit permis franco car
fallait faire un geste malgré tout vers
l'allemagne qui l'aidait économiquement
à vivre ils envoyaient la division azul
lutter contre les russes c'est à peu
près le seul résultat qui tirait obtenus
pendant quatre en guerre
[Musique]
le coup le plus sévère que le service
sss va porter à 'canaris' c'est lorsque
l'on arrête paul tu mêles l'agent à 54
paul dumel membres de l'ape vert et on
découvre qu'il a trahie l'allemagne
depuis des années qu'il a livrée aux
alliés les renseignements considérables
notamment à staline la date de l'entrée
des troupes allemandes en russie ce
n'est pas rien paul colère de haydn qui
convoque 'canaris' à prades
il faut revoir complètement le statut de
l'abwehr 'canaris' se défend comme il
peut marquer des points mais il se sent
en danger
et voilà que l' on assassine hedrich
[Musique]
et
ce n'est pas qu'elle harris qui a fait
assassiner rhétorique bien sûr mais en
face à nu en service jusqu'au moment où
il apprend que son adversaire maintenant
ce sera kaltene brunel ça n'est pas
mieux maintenant la guerre est déclarée
littéralement entre eux les ss et
l'abwehr les ss qui savent depuis
longtemps qu'il y ait un repère dans in
asie autour de kanari's qui ont vu ray
la perte de canaris c'est qu'ils n'y
parviennent pas on va arrêter par hasard
un membre de l'ape verts qui se livrent
au trafic de devises c'est un homme sem
lille parlent et ils dénoncent ils
citent des noms willy à des traîtres
dans l'entourage de l'amiral oui il a
été nommé amiral on l'appelle maintenant
le petit amiral il ya des traîtres des
gens qui médite de renverser le régime
pour terminer à la guerre ils citent des
noms des noms de collaborateurs de
canaris ce n'est les ss la gestapo
fouille les dossiers ce qu'a dit cet
homme contrôlé tel voyage telle date tel
déclaration telle date
tout cela semble vrai ont réuni un
dossier ont fait un rapport canaries
c'est en cause et on va porter ce
dossier au tout-puissant heinrich
himmler
le chef suprême des ss le reichsführer
ssc la fin de karaj c'est évident
himmler lille rapport et disjoncteur dit
qu'on touche à l'amiral 'canaris'
stupeur des hommes de la gestapo qui ont
tellement travaillé ils se remettent au
travail
il aurait unissent d'autres preuves un
nouveau rapport à une muller qui le lie
qui dit j'ai dit qu'on ne touche pas à
l'amiral canada or là on ne sait plus où
on en est il sombre c'est malheureux
hommes de la gestapo
pourquoi et müller fait il cela bien
nous le savons parce que depuis l'échec
de l'offensive d'automne 1942 en russie
himmler a des doutes sur la victoire
[Applaudissements]
et hume l'air s'est dit qu'il faudrait
négocier avec les années que les alliés
n'accepterait jamais de négocier avec
donc que c'est lui himmler qui le moment
venu se substituerait à hitler et
négocierait avec les alliés c'est fou
pensez si les alliés auraient accepté de
négocier avec l'homme qui avait installé
les camps de concentration avec le
maître de la vienne la mort plus souvent
de la mort que la vie à une ruche
humaine mais il le croyait il savait
parfaitement qu'autour de canaris sont
en faisait autant mais il ne tenait pas
ce qu'on touche 'canaris' parce que si
on touchait à callas
si on découvrait les liaisons de
l'entourage de 'canaris' avec l'étranger
on risquerait de découvrir ses propres
liaison à lui il l'est himmler protéger
'canaris' inouïe non mais il y avait une
instruction cours et il a fallu
perquisitionné au siège de la b1
possible à conakry ce de s'y opposer et
on va trouver des dossiers pas très
grave encore mais qui contiennent des
indices on va pousser plus loin en quête
si on trouvera d'autres indices et on
arrêtera d'autres gens et c'est le
moment où kaltenbrunner et d'autres
poussent leur offensive contre 'canaris'
canaris ce qui continue à jouer son jeu
il se rend en italie au moment où
l'italie bascule elle à risque y
rencontre son homologue italien lequel
lui apprend que dans quelques jours
l'italie va signer un armistice avec les
alliés canaris ce qui revient en
allemagne et qui fait un rapport qui dit
tout le contraire
l'italie nous sera fidèle scandale
autour de hitler lorsque l'italie
une armistice qu'est ce que c'est que ce
canard ici en effet il semble là que
canaris s'est joué un trop gros jeu
beaucoup trop inutile d'ailleurs il a
beaucoup lit le petit amiral ses traits
se sont creusés maintenant on dirait que
il n'ya que c'est et quelques il
intéresse il les promène partout ils
sont à son bureau le monde s'effondre
dans l'apocalypse et lui il joue avec
ses teckel peut-être est-il au fond de
lui même parvenu à cette certitude que
sa carrière est finie
peut-être aussi sa vie il n'est pas
étonné quand kite l aij oble se présente
il n'est pas étonné quand on la voit
alors einstein et quand il se promène à
la recherche de lui-même dans ce château
eh bien oui là je crois tout de même
beaucoup de mal à répondre aux questions
qu'ils se posent à lui même ville
apprend qu'il est nommé chef de la
guerre commerciale allemande
à cette époque là qu'est ce que
l'allemagne peut mener comme guerre
commerciale
le voilà à berlin il prend possession de
ses bureaux à ait quelques
collaborateurs des dossiers qu'il
compulse une sinécure rien c'est le
temps du débarquement 6 juin 44 de l'ain
soude royan tous font si vous aviez dit
[Musique]
il
romel qui envoie un message à heatley
nous ne pouvons plus nous défendre
contre les alliés il faut fureur que
vous tiriez les conséquences politiques
du désastre militaire nucléaire ne tire
aucune conséquence et c'est alors que
dans l'ombre les résistants
toujours les mêmes
avec le général bec
avec de galère avec d'autres se disent
qu' il n'y a plus qu'une solution tuer
hitler
il trouve l'homme qui fera la besogne
[Musique]
le colonel von stauffenberg et kanari's
c'est mieux au courant dès le premier
jeu auront vient le trouver n'approuve
pas mais ne désapprouve pas le petit
amiral avec c'était qu'elle sur les
genoux mais il aurait plutôt tendance à
désapprouver
pourquoi parce que je tamponne berg
d'après lui est trop à gauche et s'est
alliée avec les socialistes et même il
dit maintenant qu'il faut nouer une
alliance avec les communistes de la
résistance communiste
voilà un mot qui a toujours épouvanté
canard east et qu'il est pouvant
toujours à l'ordre il laisse faire ils
ne dénoncent pas
donnons jamais ils l'espèrent mais il
n'adhère pas le 20 juillet car on dépose
sa bombe en prusse orientale hors pair
du loup au pied de heatley
[Musique]
elle est ensuite la bombe et déplacés
hitler est sauvé
mais à berlin le coup d'état se
déclenche comme sittler et emma et est
la fin d'après midi du 20 juillet un
hamid el aris vient le trouver chez lui
et lui dit que le coup d'état est fait
mais 'canaris' reste canaris c comprend
qu'à l'heure où on est en fait le coup
d'état ne peut qu avoir échoué alors il
se lève et dit est-ce que je vais h
son boulot ou à la bndes leur strass
là où se sont réunis les conjurés qui
ont pris en charge l'allemagne d'une
croix délivré il sourit elle dit je vais
h
et quand il arrive à son bureau à la fin
de l'après-midi alors qu'on ne sait rien
encore sur la réussite ou l'échec du
complot il envoie un télégramme de
félicitations et clay pour avoir échappé
à la bombe qu'on lui avait réservé
génial ou tardif
le lendemain c'est la répression
affreux de ce terrible
[Musique]
m
le 21 austère devenu général le général
austère et arrêter tout l'entourage de
canarus le 23/07 celle en berne qui
vient l'arrêter chez liebherr qui sait
depuis quelques temps hissé au premier
rang des ss du service st et pan
'canaris' le vois je lui dis je pensais
que ce serait
schellenberg l'offre l'évasion non je ne
voudrais pas et je ne me tuerait pas il
suit celle enberg avec une petite valise
où il a réuni quelques effets une
première prison les indices se
rassemblent autour de lui on a arrêté
son successeur à la tête de l'abwehr
incertain en scène qu'il immédiatement
est passé aux aveux qui est même allé
au-delà probablement sous la torture et
qui a dit oui
l'instigateur de tout s'était garé sort
ce faux il n'est nullement l'instigateur
de la sphère duvalier et on ne prête
qu'aux riches et la gestapo en temps
avec ravissement ce qu'elle espérait
entendre depuis si longtemps est alors
cette fois transfert 'canaris' dans une
seconde prison la plus terrible celle de
la centrale ss l'enfer souterrain de la
centrale ss
cellule la m sur 2 m là il a les
menottes il est attaché au mur par des
chaînes sur la terreur on ne torture pas
mais il entend sans cesse à travers les
murs les hurlements de ses amis que l'on
tortue et il se défend admirablement
parce que canaries c'est un homme très
fort il est plus fort que ce qui la
dérange ceux ci cherchent des preuves au
fond on n'a pas de preuves hélas on va
trouver dans un coffre-fort des dossiers
gardé par les conjurés ça c'est la
méticulosité allemand est là dedans
trouve des textes à noter par 'canaris'
antérieure à 1939 au cas où la première
conjuration oreilles réussi des textes
proclamation des textes qui prouve qu'il
était au courant de la mission de joss
muller au vatican
alors cette fois il est accusé de
trahison c'est fait
trahison
on va le transférer à flossenburg
[Musique]
camp de concentration à perte de vue les
baraquements les miradors
[Musique]
il est là avec ses principaux complices
cellule 22 les chaînes toujours aux
mains et aux pieds
les interrogatoires austère et là tout
près dans la cellule 21 il ya un danois
arrêté qui va correspondre pendant tous
ces derniers jours avec 'canaris' par un
code il frappe des coups au mur vous
savez tous les prisonniers ont fait ça à
travers tous les temps et nouvelles
découvertes dans un autre coffre fort un
sens et le journal intime de canaris ce
qu'ils livrent toute sa pensée sur
éclairée elle n'est pas favorable
décision immédiate
tout ce monde doit être supprimée un ss
est désigné par kaltenbrunner
qui arrivera forcément là on va réunir
un simulacre de tribunal il y aura un
président qui sera juge qu'on est allé
chercher dans une ville voisine
l'accusateur ce sera le ss envoyé par
kaltenbrunner et n'a pas de mal à faire
l'accusateur le défenseur ce sera le
directeur de la prison
bah oui on a sous la main simulacre de
procès pour pourrait condamner tout de
suite
non parce que le ss déclare qu'il faut
pendant la nuit ce livre est un
interrogatoire poussé lundin le voisin
danois de 'canaris' n'entendra rentrée
aminés et en frappant au mur il dira je
crois qu'ils m'ont cassé le nez ils
parleront par le même code de coups
frappés au mur pendant deux heures et
canaris dictera un message disant je
crois que j'ai fait mon devoir en
empêchant en essayant d'empêcher
l'extension des folies d'hitler un peu
avant deux heures du matin dernier
message pour sa femme et ricains il
s'endort à 5h30 le lendemain matin tout
à coup l'une des miettes éveillé parce
que dans la cour des phares très
puissants se sont mis à éclairer cette
cour et il ya une honte outre une longue
charpente que l'on installé avec des
noeuds coulants qui pendent
[Musique]
et il n'entend qu'eux on ouvre la porte
de la cellule voisine cellule 22
cellules de 'canaris' ans sortait et par
la fente qu'il y a dans sa porte il voit
le petit amiral sortir avec son costume
de flanelle grise toujours et un ordre
déshabillez vous oui parce que dans le
rituel ss il faut mourir nu et il se
déshabille et on sait sortir les cinq
autres qui se déshabillent au signé l'un
après l'autre 'canaris' devant sont
conduits dans la course et kanari's qui
montrent le premier tout nu dans le
matin si froid sur l'escabeau c'est à
son cou qu'on attache le premier noeud
coulant
c'est le premier escabeau clan anvers
il y a deux témoins et c'est ce qu'ils
ont déposés après la guerre le premier a
dit heil a mis longtemps le petit amiral
il a eu deux trois secousses ya eu aussi
un médecin et c'est ce qui est dit il
est mort courageusement il est mort en
homme sûrement
il faut respecter l'homme qui est mort
de cette façon mais on dit que au moment
de mourir
on revoit sa vie l'at-il revue dans un
éclair et l'at-il comprise c'est lié la
mayral wilhelm canaries
[Musique]